[Music]
here what are you sure there's - leader
when they find out the call was traced
it somehow doesn't occur to morpheus or
Trinity that cypher is either bad at his
job or just a dick why does Trinity or
anyone for that matter from the
Nebuchadnezzar need to physically jack
into the matrix to keep an eye on neo
doesn't Morpheus watch him and see and
guide his every move in the office
building in just a few minutes I love
this opening scene as much as anyone but
it's still pretty unnecessary in the
grand scheme of keeping an eye on Neill
I think we're gonna handle one little
girl hey how come the agents don't
already know it's Trinity how come they
didn't leap into one of the cops in room
303 with Trinity at gunpoint the second
they burst into the room and saw or once
she started kicking ass it's impossible
I'm guessing agent Smith and his two
partners go around with the men in black
memory eraser after these missions doing
impossible stunts jumping into other
people and taking over their bodies
this gives away the idea of the matrix
to normal people right
Agencies Trinity running but instead of
shooting her or chasing after her
decides to want to run away as if he's
never seen running before why is the
light swinging I admit it's a cool shot
but it wasn't hit by debris or even the
wind when she doe through the window and
it stops swinging in the next shot as
evidenced by the light not moving the
agents have to visually confirm someone
like Trinity in order to know exactly
where she is so how did the agents know
to morph into this truck driver how did
they know which phone booth she would be
headed for Trinity's a dead woman if
agent Smith doesn't stop and wait here
for a few seconds to give the movie's
plot a chance to even happen come to
think of it why did he even feel
compelled to turn the vehicle couldn't
you've just smashed into the phone booth
on his way down the street truck does a
Fred Flintstone tire spin - by Trinity
even more time to barely escape truck is
always further away than it was the last
time we saw it so that this escape is
possible we have the name of their next
target
the name is new search why are the
humans able to use computers inside your
computer program to find a person by his
alias faster than well computers are how
do you not know who and where neo is
instantly neo is somehow awakened by
online chat what is this on
Neos computer monitor no person of Jesus
Christ movie hits the Jesus metaphor a
little square on the head that's racist
it's called mescaline see home movie
promptly dates itself nine minutes in
with a reference to mescaline of all
drugs why not angel dust or speed bolts
I know Morpheus could probably tell
these assholes were coming to Neos
apartment but how did he know the girl
with the white rabbit tattoo would turn
her shoulder to expose the tattoo and
how did he know neo would see it isn't
this follow the White Rabbit
just a bit too coy when the fate of the
world is in the balance my name is
Trinity as in Father Son and Holy Ghost
wait does this movie have religious
symbolism
and why was it so important to have Neil
go to the club just to tell him the
matrix is real and it will find him
I mean couldn't have typed that on the
computer instead of follow the White
Rabbit computer software company has no
mechanisms in place to determine when
flaky employees are just sitting in
their cubicle meditating instead of
doing actual work it seems like Trinity
could have given him this phone last
night at the club but Morpheus relies on
Fed Ex to send it to him LT could even
have been talking well before Neil went
into work today and he could have
avoided this altogether
also this phone is conveniently
delivered just before the agents show up
how was Morpheus able to see Neil's
location and guide him through the
building but the agents who are
connected to this entire computer system
called the matrix have no idea where neo
is what is happening computer hacker and
illegal software salesman asks why me as
FBI people chase him around his
workplace I know we're in the matrix
right now but why doesn't this thing
carving its way into Neos bellybutton
leave any blood anywhere then go to the
Morpheus gives neo a meet location on a
tapped phone and miraculously no agents
are there waiting for him when he
arrives
not that it's mattered from the time you
left your apartment to go to the Adams
Street bridge to getting in a mysterious
car also white bug neo in the first
place
can't you just track his movements
through the matrix itself remember all
I'm offering is the truth nothing more
that statement actually couldn't be less
true
dramatic thunder and lightning is
dramatic it means buckle your seatbelt
Dorothy because Kansas is going bye-bye
dramatic thunder and lightning is
repetitive here's that guy Morpheus was
interested in better disconnect him and
totally forget why he woke up in the
first place
neo pulls out this IV without knowing
what it does or whether it keeps him
alive
we have only bits and pieces of
information so all the stuff that
doesn't make sense we'll just chalk up
to that birth to a well you're a hacker
so yeah you know what AI means you don't
know who struck first but we know that
it was us that scorched the sky Oh hunt
how and how does that keep the Sun out
did they blow up the Sun how was that
accomplished how do you know about this
very specific detail and nothing else
the Oracle prophesized his return
prophecy that one man will save us all
cliche I believe that search is over
what is it that made Morpheus think neo
was the one he's a computer hacker who
works at a software company no skills in
the area of badassery nothing incredibly
notable accomplished in his life what
was the one thing that said yep the
stood is totally worth going through
lots of trouble to unplug from the
matrix oh come on it's probably a lot
more than war right son doesn't have
anything to do with the core temperature
that is hot because of a variety of
factors including radioactive decay and
awesome science stuff even if he's
talking about the mantle that is too hot
people would be burned alive going
design squiddy sleeping in one of the
human ships have radar-like ability to
detect squiddy's at greater distances
than the squiddy's can detect human
ships why didn't the machines just put
motion detection sensors all over the
place so the human ships would be unable
to move at all without being spotted
why are the squiddy's programmed only to
look for electrical signatures of the
human ships instead of biological signs
of life or hell large metal things that
are hovercraft shaped the matrix always
look at encoding well you have to wait
so when Morpheus was guiding neo through
the office cubicles was he actually
looking at falling green lines of code
is this movie actually saying these
people learn how to see real images in
this code isn't cypher jacked into some
machine back at the ship is everyone
asleep not one person who could just
happen to walk by and see cypher hooked
into the matrix and see him talking with
an agent and how does cypher get back I
thought it required someone back at the
ship to wake you up and get you out of
the matrix with a hard line is this the
first time he's eaten since he got here
for all that training and he should be
well aware of the awful non matrix food
it's very cool but how do they make a
connection on this call that there's no
one on the other end to pick it up like
neo will be racing for a ringing phone
by the end of this movie and if he could
just pick it up instead of getting shot
he'd establish the connection and
transport back out but leaping into the
matrix they still use real phone lines
but it's apparently just for show I
honestly don't know okay we're in
wait they went back into the matrix to
see the Oracle so is the Oracle part of
the matrix or she plugged in somewhere
don't even bring up the sequels when you
defend this either but I can only show
you the door you have to walk through it
what an asshole what was said was for
you and for you alone which is why I
told you what the Oracle told me while
we were on the elevator this has kind of
always bothered me even though it's
actually really cool and I accept it as
a fantastic idea but this is not deja vu
as we humans normally experience you
don't see something and then see an
absolute repeat of it two seconds later
and go WOW deja vu and you usually
experience something and feel like
you've done it before but it feels like
you did it long ago and chuck this up
the plot convenience even though it's
awesome the hole wasn't there when they
opened the door so they basically kicked
a hole in the wall without anyone
hearing it amazing neo should definitely
be dead from these bullets but it's not
time for this movies bad guys to have
good aim yet damn Smith is taking this
like he's a mannequin or something yeah
no still not time for good angle why are
there like no agents down here stopping
these guys from going back to the ship
is an important part of the plan in fact
why don't they send 20 or a hundred
agents for a mission like this that's
racist tank takes two hits from the
electricity gun but lives and is
basically fine even while only one brief
shot from the same gun later takes out
cypher completely that red pill right up
your ass you can see more if you splint
at the wind power of ciphers P in pill
is pull up plug here murderous traitor
conveniently kills good guys in the
order of their importance to the
remainder of the story no I don't
believe it I don't believe it either
ship is given codes to Zions mainframe
computer so you can't just send a
message to Zion and say yo change the
codes they got Morpheus in there gonna
make him talk peace
those are agents holding him three of
them I know I can't believe it's not
more either that's why I have to go
why because I believe in something what
neo stopped short of explaining himself
twice in a row so the Trinity and tank
have to ask him what the hell he's
talking about every mammal on this
planet want mammals are there still
other mammals out there are they hooked
up to the matrix too dreaming about
being in fields and getting taken down
by mountain lions because they're sure
as hell aren't any other mammals in the
real world what would the sky scorch
Ganahl why are you talking about all the
planets other now dead mammals in the
present tense you asked still not time
for good aim using lifts instead of
elevator proves were not in an American
city so these guys with radios heard the
call for backup in the lobby but didn't
deem it an important matter until all
the backup SWAT guys died - why are they
bursting into tell Smith about it
instead of leaping into the SWAT guys 30
seconds ago and killing me Oh what the
hell is this agent waiting for they
don't see you today oh now he pulls out
the gun and as you can see pulling it
out now has terrible disadvantages like
neo being able to dodge the bullets
Oly soon even agents with artificial
intelligence have to say some
just before they kill someone so that
the hero can be saved at the last second
dodge this however when the roles are
reversed and the good guy has to say
some bull but apparently there is not
enough time for the bad guy to get saved
honestly I know he's the one and
everything but even the one would have a
hard time seeing the agency wants to
kill and the Morpheus he doesn't want to
kill from this perspective especially
with the sprinklers going crazy on the
inside
I guess Morpheus just finally realized
there are no handcuffs this this is the
one and only moment in the movie when
the bad guy has good aim when he's being
rained on by sprinklers firing blind
from behind a wall he or she told you
exactly what you needed to hear okay
fine we're gonna go with that Star Wars
stuff where obi-wan said Anakin
Skywalker was dead and then later we
find out oh it was just a perspective I
had that wasn't misleading in any way
whatsoever but didn't you really need to
hear the Oracles prophecy about Morpheus
sacrificing his life for him and he'd
have to make a choice
wouldn't you made the choice to try and
save Morpheus anyway also why did she
literally spell out the future for
everyone else that saw her and only get
all reverse psychology on me oh the
spelling of authorized proves were not
in an American city I guarantee you
there are a hundred other homeless
people reacting to things like
pedestrians err the sky the traffic
lights with just as much enthusiasm as
this guy does and it doesn't set off any
alarms in the matrix how does the
information from this purse just woke up
vision stand out to the machines as
important from all the others homeless
people are seeing and getting excited
about all over the city tell you
something something that can wait until
after we're back on the ship but feel
the need to delay you with right now
train drives through an empty station
and never stops because it only comes
during dramatic moments cliche the one
can't find a door in plain view which
was his only option how is it possible
that none of the Nebuchadnezzar crew
remember this building from the opening
scene like Agent Smith does especially
Trinity who was cooking there
even though Neos mine believed himself
to be dead the power of boners is far
stronger and then I'm going to show
these people which you don't want them
to see for instance the two sequels to
this movie also the two sequels to this
movie try to wiggle your big toe the
answer is up there
it's looking for you and it will find
you and I will kill you understand then
hit me if you can sweep the lick got the
basic layout bookstore cafe missed
everything else is here - who are the
people projections of my subconscious
yes remember you are the dream when you
build this world I am the subject my
mind populates it you can literally talk
to my subconscious that's one of the
ways we extract information from
something for going in taking notice
here see you the Oracle
do this it's Jake from State Farm what
are you wearing
Jake from State Farm khakis she sounds
hideous I'm not afraid anymore
[Music]